welcome back to CBS this morning this
morning crews will go house to house in
the Florida Keys looking for people who
need help
hurricane Irma destroyed roadways
isolating many who didn't evacuate it
slammed into the island chain yesterday
morning the county's Emergency
Management Director is calling this a
humanitarian crisis Elaine Quijano of
our streaming network cbsn is in Key
Largo Elaine good morning good morning
when Hurricane Emma blue ashore it
brought with it a powerful surge of
water and all around here in Key Largo
we see evidence of that piles of debris
damage to the lower levels of homes like
the one behind me here and all of this
is just one example of Emma's
destructive force neighbors houses
pretty much gone the eye of the storm
landed in the middle of the Florida Keys
with all of the fury of a category 4
hurricane swelling waterways to an
estimated 10 to 15 feet in some areas
water was lapping at the steps of
Marathon High School one of only a few
shelters in the keys bill south is with
the National Weather Service he stayed
behind in Key West to work with first
responders we've been busy just trying
to get information out there to the
people to put them in the proper places
to try to save their lives
South believes the hardest hit areas
will be between big copied key and
marathon with the brunt focused on the
island of Big Pine Key debris and a
washout of the road have isolated big
pine from the other keys
what Sheila Michaela loffley wrote out
the storm in the keys she said she was
scared but is glad she didn't evacuate
for those people who live they don't
know when they're getting back in it
might not be for another two weeks so
now that we're here we can actually
start to take care of the problems and
rebuild and clean up and go from there
first responders will now be able to get
out to those hard-to-reach areas and the
military will start flying c-130 cargo
planes in to distribute supplies and
water the other logistical issue is that
authorities of asked people not to use
their boats because there are too many
pieces of dangerous debris for people to
safely move around charlie thanks Elaine